having uh
close death encounters charlie but i
imagine that's kind of what you you've
been through close death encounters
right mike yeah but um death is um
harmony life is the willingness to die
you know cause we're gonna do it anyway
so and we always um we fight it we fight
it we never we never give in to it we
fight we were born to give into it but
still we fight that's that's the sin we
have in us fighting god mm-hmm
you think you're fighting something bad
that's hurting you but you're fighting
god death is god you're not gonna get
letting go with it let's go with the
flow that was deep that was that was
actually deep remember um after your
training you talked to dre and i and you
were talking about you're born losing
already oh absolutely as the time goes
by as time goes by we lose our friends
we lose our hair
we lose our teeth we lose our sexual
desire
and we wonder why the hell i'm here
anymore everybody i love is dead
my grand i love my grandkids and my kids
and everything but they don't
they i love them you know but they don't
unders i don't understand them that's
what these old guys say i love my wife i
love my kids but i don't understand them
right right and they say you know god
takes you or the heavens take you having
to know that right is just you have to
make most of your life
live your life like there is no let me
explain the only thing that keeps us in
check the life all of us cycles and
everybody that expiration date
that's we never forget that
we forget everything else and i forget
this number we forget when our parents
call we never forget the possibility of
that expiration date
that's the only thing that keeps us in
perspective makes us work hard for our
kids until that expiration date comes
you know once you get conscious of the
expiration date you become a totally
different person you look at life
totally different right you're looking
about what you can leave before you go
[Music]
you